すき家の柔道は
数なんで飽きるのか1日目の朝でございます飽きる自身はないんですよずっと取り
続けるんですけどさすがに1週間の3色をなるべく全部融合にすると話せ周南で牛丼は
飽きるのかというちょっとずいぶんへの挑戦でございます
立秋完全見てたら週21式やになり
ニュースうううっ
ゴリオりっこ
ナイスはうマンション沼にの知ってる上での挑戦で派
今回はん
ん
ええええええ
子供ですと錯乱するとつかというか穴2つめの1食目です急盗んでございますいただき
ます
[音楽]
ん
2があっていません
ああああああ
んじゃん
坊
me
ん
交通課まで2まだ全然大丈夫問題ね
まずも美味しいですね流動に対する飽きる要素もございません
では3食目夜でございます
いただきます
[音楽]
ん
おっ
me
運動様でした3食目からつか味わえない肉本来この噛むことによって生じる2区にある
味の甘み国家のが効果無効によって感じることができますそんな20かわかんねーなら
ば休みになります
me
そろそろ車
いただきます
dee
チューナの柱盗んでございます
あ
[音楽]
ん
1着ない
もう行きたくないよー
ます
[音楽]
ちょっともうしません
ええええええ
me
主従部でいただきます
[音楽]
はいいただきます
me
言われますさすがに集14となると母もなく肉の旨人様の完全に分かりきっている自信
があります味の性質というかすき家の牛丼ならではの特徴
[音楽]
tan
me
[音楽]
数19なります
ていた
wh
週に10回目でていただきます
[音楽]
好きな生活数21回目に行ってまいりました
ここまで作ってくださった全国のすき家で働いている皆様いつもご苦労様でございます
いただきます
ああああああ
最後に宇部やとんどうっポッ
me
べーわー結構に甘いん
日差しの
me
それじゃあん
[音楽]
ni
太ったかな
me
うううう
ni
car
バッハ